hello and welcome to the new world
review your souls for everything anime
and manga and today we are going to be
examining the ever beautiful concept of
nen now nen is the underlying power
system featured in hunter hunter and is
a force of versatility that can be
applied to seemingly infinite outcomes
ranging from basic invitations to
out-of-this-world maddening abilities in
fact according to the fabric of Hunter
hunter the use of nen whether
consciously or subconsciously is
responsible for producing exceptional
individuals in this world such as
athletes and geniuses as such nen is
significantly more complex than most
shown in power systems but we're going
to be doing our best to break it down in
its simplest elements here and then
maybe later on we'll have a much more
advanced video but trust me even the
simple elements take a lot to understand
so nen begins with the idea that every
living being possesses their own brand
of life energy which is referred to as
aura in the series this aura is produced
from all parts of the body via various
aura nodes and it has a tendency to flow
together creating a mass of travelling
energy however this generally happens
without the awareness of said living
being which results in a slow leak of
aura escaping the body from the top of
the head which can be described as kind
of like steam escaping from the opening
of the boiling kettle however one can
learn to halt this leakage and control
their aura which is the beginning of the
art known as nen now learning nen starts
with the essential step of understanding
how to manually control the opening and
closing of one's aura nodes and the
traditional way to achieve this is
through a slow process of meditation and
bodily enlightenment however if you like
me are incredibly impatient then there
is a more frowned upon method which is
colloquially referred to as an
initiation this method involves forcing
one's aura notes open through a rapid
influx of aura being forced into them by
another party who can already control
their own aura this method is
particularly dangerous because it can
lead to heavy exhaustion as well as
permanent damage and in fact in the
world of nen this methodology is even
referred to as an attack due to the
potential for it to be performed with
malicious intent although this rough
methodology is not the only way to go
about forcing aura notes open as it has
been shown that an experienced nen user
can open a student's aura nodes by the
use of a simple heart - now what is a
heart so you ask well that is a
wonderful question and it lead us to the
Shingen REO school of kung-fu
founded by a certain Isaac Metro and it
teaches its students four major
principles and applications of nen those
being ten zetsu Ren and Hart su and to
go through all of those starting with
ten this is the mastery of keeping one's
aura nodes open but concentrating the
flow of aura around the body rather than
having it leak and dissipate from it due
to ten focusing on maintaining your aura
users of this basic principle will
increase longevity thanks to the
hoarding of their own life energy rather
than letting it escape furthermore ten
can also act as a very basic defense
against emotional nan attacks as well as
limited protection against physical nan
attacks then we have the next major
principle of zetsu which takes this a
step further and focuses on suppressing
the flow of or are altogether by
manually closing one's aura nodes in
terms of practical usage it is generally
performed to mask once or from other nen
users as well as to increase your own
sensitivity to the aura of others
however rather notably when a user is in
a state of zetsu then they are at their
most vulnerable because they have no
aura to defend them and even the most
basic of nen infused attacks or
abilities can cause fatal damage to the
unprotected minds and bodies of those
engaged in zetsu next up is Ren which
aims to use or offensively by projecting
a large amount in an outward and
explosive manner thus providing the user
with enhanced physical abilities as well
as an easily accessible pool of aura
required for engaging in more advanced
and abilities and finally we have the
aforementioned hot soup which is
probably best described as the users
very own personal expression of net like
a manifestation and an application of
aura resulting in a truly unique ability
that generally adheres to the natural
affinity of an end user for example
killer's ability to seemingly create
electricity out of thin air is a heart
true that he was able to develop by
transmuting his aura into a substance
that mimics the properties of
electricity now that I've mentioned the
T word being transmutation this seems to
be a good time to delve into our next
layer of the known world which is that
in addition to the basic applications of
Nan that I've listed here every living
being in this world actually has a
natural affinity for one of the
following six different aura types which
are as follows first up enhancement
using this brand an individual is able
to use their aura to increase the
natural abilities of an object or even
one's own body so it's great to
strengthen your offense and also
wonderful to strengthen your defense as
well the very balanced category all
around although it does mostly get
applied to boost one's basic combat
prowl
for example one of our main protagonists
confreaks is a natural enhancer and he
applied that principle to develop an
attack named rock which basically gives
him a super-powered fist although
admittedly it is a bit more complicated
than that and gone does invoke some more
advanced principles of Nan which we will
get into in a bit but next up is
transmutation so just as with the
example I mentioned earlier featuring
Kilwa a transmuter is able to change the
properties of their aura to mimic those
of something else and this can be just
about anything but it doesn't end with
simple imitation as a transmuter is also
capable of choosing selective properties
of the substance they wish to mimic and
can even craft their own personalized
substance a great example of this would
be Hisoka a natural transmuter whose
bungee-jump hatsue is able to mimic the
properties of both rubber and gum
although it is infinitely more flexible
and sticky than either substance would
be in reality moving along we have
conjuration and practitioners of this
ability are able to morph their aura
into a physical and independent object
according to their own desired laws and
principles now this can often be
mistaken for transmutation which I just
went over but the key difference here is
that conjurer's can create independent
objects and to illustrate this kite
would be a great example who invokes
conjuration to create his weapons that's
born from his crazy sensibility that are
put to use as independent objects rather
than a substance to be wielded as with
transmute as the next category is
emission and users of this type have
easy access to detaching pure aura from
their bodies leading to a whole host of
long-range net options furthermore
emitters are not to be confused with
conjurer's as emitters are only capable
of separating pure forms of aura rather
than creating physical objects and a
cool example of this would be Razer who
rather simply emits a Bulevar and uses
it as a long-range weapon such fun
gameplay mechanic when engaged in a
dodgeball match the fifth brand is that
of manipulation and those considered
manipulators possess the power to
control both living and nonliving things
including or constructs and all this is
accessible by applying their own aura so
basic applications of manipulation can
be achieved by pouring ones or R into an
existing object not to be confused with
one conjured by nen and to illustrate we
have illumise all tix needles which are
infused with aura and are then able to
control individuals in a wide variety of
ways upon insertion of the needles into
their bodies and just very briefly mind
control in general is a massive
sub-genre of manipulation and can be
broken down
into further subcategories that I won't
go into here but they include soliciting
coercive pseudo coercive and the other
mysterious and longley worded diffusive
induction type but finally we have
probably what is the most insane horror
type which is that for specialists which
can be summarized as any form of known
ability that does not fit into the
previous five categories now at first
specialists would seem like just a
miscellaneous category for any
application of aura that does not fit
into the established groups and that is
true to some extent with a good example
of this being neon Lestrade who had the
lovely Ghost Rider ability where she
could predict people's futures through
cryptic poetry once certain conditions
were met however specialists are not
limited to miscellaneous powers and they
can quite blatantly break the core rules
of Nan and its applications so we're the
proficient specialist you can
essentially throw the rules of Nan out
the window because you can never predict
what they will be capable of achieving
now as mentioned before every individual
is born with an affinity for one of
these six times however that does not
mean that they can never access the
others far from it actually so let's say
for example that you like gone freaks
were born as an enhancer that would mean
that should you learn then then you have
the potential to be 100% efficient in
any pure enhancement invocation of aura
however as we expand to your adjacent
typings that percentage drops to 80 and
taking another step further out drops
down to 60 until you reach the Taiping
furthest away from you which leaves you
with a 40% potential efficiency and all
of this is true except in the case of
specialization actually because here's
the thing if you are not a specialist
then it is impossible for you to access
that brand of aura however because none
is an N there is always a possibility of
becoming a specialist later in life with
its two adjacent categories of
manipulators and conjurors having the
highest chance of doing so but
specialization aside a proficient nen
user can more or less access every other
brand of aura but to varying degrees of
success and once again you can say this
in gone who is a natural enhancer that
also has attacks based on using its
adjacent categories being transmutation
and omission and with this in mind using
nen immediately becomes a lot more
complicated because not only can you
access every class bar specialization
that you can also use these aura
applications in combination with one
another to manifest a unique answer and
in fact most experienced end users will
smoothly blend any number of these
disciplines together for instance xenos
old extract and dye part 2 is only
possible through using omission to
create the drag
Dora and transmutation to imbue it with
its destructive properties and then
going even crazier we can take a brief
look at crop occurs judgment chain
ability which is a combination of three
different typing's being conjuration
emission and manipulation which
basically has the effect of bringing a
chain into existence which upon striking
an opponent can force a condition of
Caracas choosing onto them but taking a
step back just for a second all of these
hearts who are not the be-all and
end-all of Nan as the four major
principles can be expanded upon for more
advanced use in a variety of different
ways firstly a user can adapt the
principle of rennes and focus it
specifically around their eyes create
the technique known as go the benefit of
this concentration of aura is being able
to see the aura of other nen users even
those concealed by een speaking of ena
is an advancement of zetsu which renders
it uses or are masked from other nen
users but unlike zetsu it does not stop
the aura flow but rather it just
conceals it making it extraordinarily
appealing to those who don't wish to
draw attention to themselves but also
don't wish to leave themselves
defenseless either then there's also n
which is a combination of 10 and Ren
allowing a radial expansion of aura that
has the result of giving the user the
ability to sense everything within it
and we can keep compounding these
abilities in which case we end up with
stuff like ko which combines ten Ren
zetsu Tatsu and go to effectively make
one particular part of the users body
incredibly powerful at the cost of
leaving everything else entirely
defenseless but you get the idea there
is a huge field of advanced techniques
out there to pursue however more
importantly it should be noted that aura
is not a simple scientific substance and
it can be quite easily manipulated by
personal factors such as emotion this is
because aura is directly tied to its
user and as a result it is heavily
influenced by their emotional state in
fact one commonly view phenomenon occurs
when a person channels their aggression
into their aura and deploys it at a
target through the basic principle of
rent this is known as the bloodlust
phenomenon and makes a target feel
physically antagonized by said bloodlust
as if it were physically palpable and
desires like this can even
subconsciously mold aura and bestow
people with abilities that they never
actively trained for such as when Biscay
became capable of changing her
appearance through the symbol but
extreme desire of wishing for her body
to change over a period of many many
years and despite being a direct
representation of lifeforce the aura of
an end user does not necessarily
disappear after death
in fact on several occasion
it has been shown to be quite the
opposite and Brandt exponential power
usually as the result of the user
feeling an overwhelming emotion prior to
them passing away so for example this
was despite quite clearly when NetHope
toes top sakura took control of her
corpse and proceeded to attack gone due
to the feelings of loyalty NetHope toe
had for the Chimera ant king mara well
and in fact certain end users have even
gone so fast making their own death an
activation requirement for a certain
ability such as Hisoka programing his
Bungie gum Honsou to restart his heart
after death but speaking of conditions
these are a very important aspect of Nan
bringing up the idea that nen is
directly tied to emotions and desires so
as a result users are entirely capable
of bargaining with their own powers by
saddling them with strict activation
requirements in order to invoke greater
power and a prime candidate of this who
we've already mentioned in this video
would be karappa whose requirement to
use the chain Jail technique is that he
can only perform it against a member of
the Phantom troupe so should Cara pick
of violate this condition it will result
in his instantaneous death however when
performed under the right conditions
change l is an incredibly overpowered
technique that will leave essentially
any member of the Phantom troupe
entirely incapable of dealing with it
the conditions don't have to be quite as
extreme as death though as demonstrated
by knuckle whose activation requirement
for haka water is simply to land a punch
on an opponent but of course the more
complex conditions and restrictions
placed on an ability then well it will
generally result in significantly
greater power upon meeting them and one
of the most intriguing examples of this
would be the Bandit secret hearts who
developed micro Lucifer now this power
basically allows chrono to steal the nen
ability of another user
however he has to meet the following
four conditions before being able to do
sir firstly krohler must witness the
desired ability in action with his own
eyes secondly he must ask the user about
the ability and then have his question
answered by the user then and probably
the most difficult condition his victims
mom needs to touch the handprint on the
cover of Mantid secret and finally all
of this needs to be accomplished within
one hour so those four criteria are
absolutely ridiculous conditions to
satisfy but if krolow is able to achieve
it and he can blatantly steal the hearts
with other people and you know despite
knowing all of this nen is still an
incredibly mysterious subject and full
of a lot of depths so for example while
unknown abilities are based on a user
this does not necessarily mean that all
in abilities are unique and there are a
lot of
cognizable subcategories to classify
more commonly generated hot suit such as
cloning creating n beasts and curses or
even exorcism and honestly these are
concepts that require a ton of time
stove into and I may make an entire
video on them if all of you are
interested to hear about that sort of
stuff in a bit more depth but as for
right now all I can say is that this
series has consistently introduced new
and interesting methods of menus
it is a vast well of infinite
possibilities that is limited only by
the needs and creativity of its user and
that very much makes it quite possibly
the most versatile power system in all
of fiction if that pretty much does it
for the basics of net if you enjoyed
this video and the content this channel
produced in general then please do
consider donating to the new world
review patreon because the support of
all of your amazing people is what
continues to make this channel possible
and if patreon isn't quite your style
then please do leave this video a like
share or subscribe because it also helps
for this channel an incredible amount
and if you'd like to join the fun at any
time then please do head over to my
discourse over where a wide array of
shenanigan ray takes place on a daily
basis and finally please do comment with
your own thoughts on men this has been
the new world review and I'll see you
next time